today was the White House Easter Egg
Roll they had that Easter Egg Roll at
the White House yeah at today's Easter
Egg Roll White House press secretary
Sean Spicer read a book to children
isn't that nice
that's true he read a book the children
afterwards all the kids have the same
question
who's Hitler Melania Trump was at the
ceremony today yeah she well yeah yeah
today at the White House Easter
festivities manya Trump kicked things
off by blowing a whistle she did she
started the whole thing by blowing a
whistle then again most women standing
near Donald Trump end up having to blow
a whistle what
Gradius right here what this Navy SEAL
let's come out that a Navy SEAL has been
moonlighting for seven years as a porn
star yes
even more surprising it turns out that
the guy who killed Osama bin Laden was
ron jeremy yeah he had yeah you don't
want to know how how we doing no good
we're good
according to a new survey that just came
out 44% of people would rather take a
longer flight that costs more than fly
United Airlines longer costs more yeah
when they heard this American Airlines
said done and done
scientists are now claiming that every
hour spent running every hour spent
running increases your life span by
seven hours seven hours incredible yeah
in other words majority of Americans
died three years ago
and I'm one of them
science fascinating science news
researchers have begun testing the
possibility of using sperm to deliver
life-saving drugs to specific parts of
the female body yes that's true yeah but
first they're going to have guys test
this out as a pickup line
I got just what you need a couple from
Florida just set a record by taking
their 200th Carnival Cruise 200 Carnival
Cruises 200 Carnival Cruises yeah the
couple said what can we say we love
diarrhea it just makes us happy it
brings us together
if it keeps couples together
you